Speaker 1: This next segment is going to be the
totality of my coverage of the Turning Point USA
Women's Summit. Many of you sent me clips from
this summit, Lauren Boebert and others speaking.
It was a totally insane event. Turning Point
USA Is this on campus? Right wing organization.
They did an event over the weekend which was
specifically for young right wing women. I
guess I'm just going to look at one piece
of it with you so we can say we looked at
that sort of stuff that was going on there. I'm
going to play a clip for you where a woman in
the audience tells a story about transpeople in
the bathroom with her. And then Marjorie Taylor
GREENE goes transphobic and says, listen, trans
people in bathrooms, they're in there to have
sex with you. That's why they're there.
Speaker 5: Last year, I got my modesty
and dignity taken away from me. When I
found out that my school had put multiple
biological males in my locker room and right
rooms, some of which will just sit there and
watch me and the other girls change.
Speaker 1: Okay, That's already not
okay. If they love to pretend, they love to
pretend that this is all about trans people,
anybody who just hangs out in a locker room or a
bathroom checking people out can be reported. It
doesn't matter what their gender identity is.
Either way, the behavior isn't allowed, which
immediately makes me skeptical about this story.
Speaker 5: I'm just trying to dress in peace and
be able to go to our classes. Me and my dad made
quite a fuss last year at my school and in my
community, and I've spoken in front of my very
woke school board many times. However, nothing
seems to happen even though they are violated
thousands of girls every day. Do you have any
advice for me as a 16 year old trying to change
the mind of adults and make a difference? Wow.
First of all, thank you for your courage.
Speaker 1: Right? Because. Yes. Thank you.
Speaker 5: Because when you when you're speaking
out in your school to your school board,
you and your father and your family and
you're standing up against men who are
really a bunch of perverts in your locker
room, in your bathroom, because they listen.
They want to have sex with you. That's why they're
in there. That's real. They are It's not they're
not saying, oh, I identify as a woman and I'm
only attracted to men. That is, they lie. These
are sexual predators. They're sexual predators.
Speaker 1: There are statistically almost zero
incidents of the kind that they would
have you believe are rampant there. It
just it just doesn't happen like this.
Speaker 5: My advice for you is your
safety is number one, ladies. Your safety is
number one. And that when you all join together
and make that known and refuse to accept.
Speaker 1: This, this is also disgusting,
as I've said before. Do you really think
that actual violent predators are going to
be dissuaded by the gender sign on the bathroom
door? It's absurd and ridiculous. And of course,
when then you go further and say, well,
there must be hundreds or thousands or at
least dozens of incidents where based
on a falsely stated gender identity,
someone hid out in a bathroom and then assault,
you find out that it is essentially nonexistent
and it is all part of the story that they use
to prop up this anti-trans, anti-trans paranoia
that they are now obsessed with and that they
are raising money around at the end of the day.